david i know you think trump won't be
arrested but will he be investigated
when he leaves office
so uh almost certainly there are going
to be investigations of donald trump's
businesses there's going to be a lot of
financial crime investigation it's
possible that even
people close to donald trump are going
to go down
uh but yeah i still don't think you're
ever going to see trump
in prison there are a lot of people who
rightly are feeling
that if donald trump isn't personally
prosecuted
that um an injustice has been done
and i am not arguing that trump has done
nothing
worthy of being investigated and
potentially charged with criminality
but this is not a country that does that
and i know that that
upsets lots of people and some people
like the fact that this is not a country
that every time you get a new president
they investigate
charge and potentially even imprison the
previous president it's not a country
that does that i don't think we're going
to see that what we will see
are investigations into donald trump's
business dealings
and financial stuff i think that trump's
enablers
can and should be prosecuted directly
when it applies
this includes family this includes
republican senators this includes other
functionaries
people involved in enabling um a
illegal activity even if it's
financially illegal activity if such
activity exists
they should be harshly penalized as far
as trump goes
i don't think it'll touch trump i think
there's
the real possibility that his businesses
will end up having to
settle and pay absolutely massive fines
it's conceivable that if you find people
involved in trump's businesses caught
red-handed
with financial fraud money laundering
whatever it's possible
they may end up uh convicted i just
don't think it's going to touch trump
and i don't think it's going to be for
political crimes it'll be
a tax evasion money laundering
uh improper use of charities which
donald trump has already been been
caught doing i think it will be that
type of thing
i do believe that trump is worried
because trump doesn't know we've
we had a few reports from right before
the election that part of why trump is
panicking
is because he's worried that the rest of
his life will be riddled uh by
investigations
and maybe he could end up in prison i
just don't think he'll end up in prison
i think it's completely plausible
that you do see investigations of
different kinds
plague the rest of donald trump's life
now
the on the other side there's people
asking about pardons couldn't trump
preemptively pardon everybody who's
likely to be wrapped up in this
you know i think there's two things that
will prevent that from happening number
one
i don't think trump really cares about
these people trump doesn't care about
his supporters
it's not clear trump even cares about
his enablers
and that's one part of it the other part
of this is
trump has not shown himself to be
detail-oriented enough
to actually figure out who is it that i
need to grant blanket pre-emptive
pardons for so i don't think that trump
will do it he may do it with some i
don't think he will get to everybody
and then the other reason i think you
are going to see a deluge of
investigations and possible charges
after trump is out of office
when it comes to his associates is look
at how many trump associates
were convicted while donald trump was in
office
with the department of justice
encumbered by
trump loyalists running interference
once trump is gone and you have a
different justice department i think you
will see many more trump acolytes go
down
now the last thing i want to say about
this joe biden shouldn't be involved in
this at all remember when trump was
saying to hillary during the 2016
debates
if i was president you'd be locked up
and we're going to investigate you in
all of this stuff and in fact while
trump was president
he tried to push the justice department
can't you investigate biden can't you do
this can't you do that
joe biden should have no involvement
whatsoever in any possible
investigations of anybody associated
with donald trump
i don't believe joe biden will do that
joe biden has shown no interest in that
he's shown no willingness to do that
and to be perfectly frank even if he
liked the idea of being involved in
investigations of trump joe biden's
going to have his hands more than full
uh trying to clean up the mess from uh
from from donald trump
and uh he will be plenty busy and i
believe that the next department of
justice will also be very very busy
look at what escaped the trump bubble
while he was president that we learned
about in terms of criminality
imagine what we're going to learn about
once he's finally gone